I gave that I gave Zach a fake phone
number yeah I was like he wasn't
responding to any of my attack
do I have your real phone no not yet I
refused to give it to you that I am I
rescued a dog and he was a puppy and he
got away but he knew not to go sir when
I like just ran out in the yard to go
save him so he would run into the street
just in my underwear I just woke up and
like snagged him and was like no don't
run away
and and I looked up my neighbor this
whole family with like what style did
the Real Housewives sophistical like an
anger drink thrown in LA I've had
comedic drinks thrown in my face I don't
think I've either I had someone once a
girl flicked a cigarette in my face
also bad probably worse than one time I
threw a party and I heard someone go
holy [ __ ] Seth Rogen's here and I was
like man it's my house that's not what
you want to hear in your own house
never actually one dance panel I don't
know who ranks these things so I think
I'm good yeah at some point I jump in
and everybody gets excited and you win
yeah I guess I want but it's it's never
like step up there's never really a
winner yeah it's not like I'm on stage
with oh yeah it's like yeah it's like
whoa
yeah the other team just like crap yeah
yeah but I used to live next to a guy
who would have a lot of sex whereas I
did not you have you heard it yeah
unless somebody's getting yeah mrs.
abhart I always assume it's a murder
I didn't have a crush on him but again
my neighbor who [ __ ] a lot seemed like
if that was my thing he would be a great
dude to go after cuz he seemed to have
some prowess in that department
so he wasn't my orientation but if he
was I would have gone for him because
he'd [ __ ] like a lunatic